what's up fellow gearos we have the
hotly anticipated Lenovo Legion go in
the house today and I got to say it is
quite a big boy and come stack with a
very unique feature you're able to use
this detachable remote sa Mouse for FPS
games which we will be trying out as
well we will be playing a whole bunch of
games I'm course 6 F Rubicon cyberp Punk
2077 Call of Duty Mod Warfare 3 and
Forza Horizon 5 and see how well this
console handles them performance- wise
the Lenovo Legion go that we have runs
an AMD ryzen Z1 extreme for CPU the AMD
rdna 3 for its GPU 16 gigs of RAM 512
gigs of storage and everything plays out
on 8.8 in IPS 16 X10 quart HD Plus 144
HZ monitor with a 49.2 hour battery and
it comes with two detachable controllers
with the right controller being the one
fitted with FPS mode and both
controllers have a 900 mAh battery so
we're going to be starting things off
strong let's go to the menu and check
our performance settings the thing about
portable gaming consoles is that you're
going to need to tweak the performance
as you go and obviously it depends on
the game so we'll be running this at a
custom 30 wats for the performance and
Os power mode will be at performance as
well so we are also running this at 2560
x600 first and we'll see how the console
handles the games later on so everything
else 144 HZ refresh rate we've also got
the frame rate monitor on thermal modes
at custom 30 wats so you can actually
access the power settings in this menu
right here here one more thing you want
to do before running games on the legion
go is to turn it on and get into the bio
so you're going be turning it on and
pressing on both volume buttons to enter
the
BIOS and we are already in nice all
right and get the more settings what
you're going to do is go into
configuration and change the um frame
buffer size from the default that's 3G
to 6G or even 8G we'll be sticking the
6G for
now and the other thing that you want to
do is to change up the charging speed
selection cuz by default it's slow so
obviously change it to fast and once
you're done with everything just exit
saving changes so while that's setting
up for Call of Duty we're going to be
playing in the FPS mode so what you're
going to do is flip it around there's
this little switch at the corner down
here you're going to push it inwards and
then slide it out just like that and it
comes right off we're going to be
removing this as well to make things
easier and then to turn on FPS mode the
switch is at the bottom and just turn it
right on and we're going to be placing
it in this here little holster like that
this little Mount and this is magnetic
so this is how it's going to be oriented
like the contact will be facing you
while the mouse one and mouse 2os are at
the front so you'll be playing like this
I'll be setting up a camera over there
so you guys have a better idea of how
it's like to play with this thing
currently at 2560 x600 144 Herz all
right let's check performance and th
mode at 30 custom 30 OS power to
Performance so with that let us get into
a match and let's actually just check
out set things for Call of Duty real
quick as well so for graphics quality
we're going to be going with ultra real
quick just to see how it's
like and okay apply that displaying
everything as it is all right okay it's
cool okay so that let's try let's just
try to get into a game real quick but
honestly if this doesn't work out I'm
going down to recommended performance
settings H because that's the most
likely settings that everyone else use
for a handheld like
this all right need to get used it's
going to take a bit of getting used too
when it comes to this
controller oh boy that's bad
oh I mean my aim of course with this
thing you will need to take time to get
used to
this but you know obviously you wouldn't
be using this for like competitive
gameplay or just m to play in general at
for something that isn't as competitive
like say like Minecraft or something
sure you can use this but um yeah I
still recommend this for single player
games let's see if we can get sniper
kill this thing and honestly if I if I
don't get one it's
fine
stand
damn it okay let's change up setting
something more manageable for the nor
Legion gr quality let's go to balanced
actually damn it okay not doing very
well my K is going to take a huge hit
after this but at least we're kind of a
steady 30 is
quite interesting for
Balan we obviously can bring higher of
course we are playing this at 2560 by,
1600 and if we bring it even lower we'll
get obviously we'll obviously get a
higher FPS but for where we at right now
this is this is pretty good so uh let's
actually just reduce all those setting
to something that's a bit more optimized
and for performance with the Lenova
Legion go for the handheld section of
this okay so we're going to bring the
resolution down to 1280 by 800 and
everything else should be the same all
right go to Graphics uh Mr the auto
changed the display resolution so that's
great and let's go to Quality is could
put it on the
recommended for
performance and we should be getting
much higher frame rate see like 84 so
let's just see how this turns out oh and
before that remember to always change up
the cursor settings you don't want to
get caught with the pants down all the
control input the Amy input as it were
from Mouse to controller because the
game doesn't detect that change on the
console so you need to manually change
it
up all right so we're jumping straight
into a active match and look at that 90
FPS 100 FPS even that's quite steady
this is hella
smooth I think I'll be able to do much
more damage like
this I will admit
that trust me it will take some time to
get used to playing like this for
anyone damn
it all right but at least you know like
everything's have been at 100ish FPS so
things have been looking very
smooth and I finally got three kills
wow to string together at least a kill
streak out of this so I don't think
that's too bad as you can see this thing
plays pretty well especially once you've
optimized the settings look at that we
hitting we hit around like 100ish
average FPS for this match and things
looking really good we are on all of our
settings right now let's just check it
out real quick 25 60 x600 144 HZ all of
the performance ratings are still the
same as before so let's check our
settings in game and we're going to be
playing this on
high and we're going to be playing this
on high under quick presets I'll you
know what let's just try Ultra just for
funsies and let's just continue it's
like ready
oh 16 18 Let's
Ride
yeah that's that's really choppy some
almost at 23 right now but yeah let's
not do this let's just bring it down an
Notch more uh let's go to settings real
quick settings and let's bring it down
to I want to say high let just go to
medium and see how that works out for
us all right that's a lot bat though
nice all right so look at that 25 but I
think we can do much better let's go
down to
low
all right and we're at 30 FPS for 2560
by 1600 speed 28 33 okay so it's kind of
hovering right now but it's relatively
smooth firi we're at 30 FPS right
now
God damn it God damn it okay we reload
all right let's uh overheat this guy
quick
reloading yeah let's get
him all right
cool everything is in order all right
that was pretty smooth obviously again
you need to take some time to get used
to playing with the handheld mode and
the controller so with that I think we
can optimize this even further let's
bring this down to 1280 and see how much
more we can bump the
performance all right we change up 1280
let's change up in the settings as
well all right we've changed it up and
as you can see once you change
everything up look at those numbers we
flying at least 860 FPS just as I said
it all right so this is running pretty
smoothly and the settings we have the
legion go running on right now and okay
let's let's just try and get through a g
and the only thing about night of Ty
Punky General is that you know using
fast travel doesn't feel right so like
many of us we just want to drive
straight into the
city oh boy
let's get
out yeah we need 38,000 at so let's just
kill this real
quick all right and no know what's going
to happen next and just quietly go
inside but then there's this thing here
which is the server room
scientists from biodine systems have
announced a breakr in fight
sceris all right then none the
Riser all right nice little bit of steth
action except how did the guys see me
from Below
I'm not
sure all right we going need to find
that CR
chip which should
be on this
fellow oh where is that V
CH okay I guess we're going to be
fighting our way
out could have been more subtle but uh
let's find a way
out we had to go loud things are going
kind of well but never
mind it's not exactly clean getaway but
yep at least it's bright out
now okay let's just deposit the
things and that's it that's it for the
job
run your
down come
on damn it okay that's my fault let's
kill this shoot so I think we've seen
enough of what the legion can do with Cy
Punk 277 so with that let's move to our
next game okay so we're going to get
into armed core right now let's check
our settings real quick um let's go back
2560 by 1600 144 Herz but thing alac
call you know is that the max is 120 HZ
so just keep that in mind and obviously
our thermal mode and Os power mode are
all set the highest so with that let's
just get into arm call 6 fire a
Rubicon all right system let's go to
graphics and let's change this up to 25
60x 600x 16 by 10 yeah just keep that
and we're going to go on high for now uh
we can try maximum but I know for a fact
that that will make things a bit slow
but let's see how the garage looks like
usually the garage is quite indicative
of the performance of how second game
and as you can see we're at 23 24 FPS so
let's just try going to the arena all
right so uh cut w at 20 24 FPS which
isn't super hot let's just try and get
in game I I chose igua because of like
the citycape are thing and as you can
see it's all
right obviously you can do much
better but you know like with this thing
especially with armor C six you know
you're going to need a lot more than
just pury Graphics to win matches or
duels like this so because you
definitely need to have a smoother and
much higher FPS in order to pick up all
the quick movements of other mechs and
whatever it is you go up against that
they put you in this game so uh let's
just change things up let's go to
system uh let's go down a notch let's go
down by a couple notches actually let's
go
into
medium see how that performs so at
medium we are kind of like a constant is
the
tfps and we aren't exactly what it
called fighting U right
now
okay and we won that by such a thin
margin but as you can see it's kind of
playable at medium at 356 by 1600 but
let's just really find a way to at least
try to get it up to kind of like 8 to
100 FPS reducing it by quite a bit we're
going to go down to
1280 going to go to 1280 we're going to
keep the FPS at 120 of course and all
right once that's done let's just get
out this menu first all right let's go
do system
settings there our Graphics right and
let's just bring this on 1280
by uh let's go 1280 by 86 by
10 yes that's our that's our correct
that think yes correct and all right
let's give you the medium and see how it
performs let's go the
opener
no I missed the shot oh my God okay I
didn't lock on to him that's my
bad okay again it think I'm getting used
to the controls I'm dead again damn it
come
on and we got him and yeah as you can
see we still are hovering just below 70
FPS and honestly just depends on how
many enemies and how many SES there are
in the area so with that let's just try
and get into a
sorty oh damn it that's
bad oh damn I reading up play well okay
you it will take some time to get used
to this I will have to say that again
but then he's
down
okay still doing a I believe I know
there are other objectives over here but
I'm just going to try to fly past
everything pretty
quickly let's go
down and we're going to be heading the a
lot of sniper fire
here there is a lot of fire going on
right
now TR do anything about
this oh wait I think they can all let's
keep going
all right let's get the missiles
first it's a lot of
missiles here we go but yeah as you can
tell I'm actually having a pretty good
time playing this thing again it will
take some time to get used to you know
just playing with a handheld in general
and of course
getting used to holding up like that I'm
actually in a semi awkward position
playing this thing as I usually am when
it comes to these videos but I will say
it's it's it's really quite fun playing
on this thing we are getting at least
smooth gameplay we can't push up 120 HZ
120 FPS I mean we can't push up 120 FPS
but this is the best I can do and
honestly if you can play arm call on the
go I'm more than happy to to play arm
call On The Go
controls
all right let's draw in need to be smart
with this CU I've never been SP about
this
before here we
go
there we go that's one down and we still
have enough Health to deal with the last
guy come
on
okay we missed that
completely still not so bad
and die okay finally got him and with
that as you can see in kind of 77 in
70ish fps right here and honestly it's
playable especially on battery and
currently we at 52% battery so on the
way to work and on the way home on your
commute so this this does the job so now
they're in the game let's check our
options
and let's try going on the highest real
quick which should be extreme which I
know won't exactly turn out super well
but let's just see how well we
do and on Extreme we're at 23
FPS from what it seems oh get lost the
memory okay so we kind of we kind of
extreme Let's uh bring it down a much
bigger not let's go to
High
and for some reason the FPS counter is
not working I think we're running like
maybe at 50 or 60 I'm trying
to okay never mind we do have enough
system memory for high so let's uh bring
it down even more fix on high and let's
bring it down to
low I don't want to go through every
step so we're kind of hovering between
52 to kind of low to high 50s for the
FPS so let's actually just keep driving
through see how this goes so far oh you
hit 60 nice yeah it's running pretty
smoo it actually looks really good in
person I think if you were you know
again to play with this on the goal this
would be
amazing okay so so far we're doing
pretty okay everything's still kind of
bordering is kind of 59 is nothing more
than that but I think that's all we need
so actually let's uh change our
performance settings real quick and of
course that means we need to
um bring everything down all right so
let's just go down to graphics and then
check it out oh sorry no video sorry and
bring this down to 1280 by 800 and yep
let's just save that keep it and let's
continue and as you can see we're at 103
FPS right
now O Okay 88 I don't think we can get
it to like to 144 but this is really
good enough honestly
this is definitely the place okay yeah
so fora Riz 5 is pretty much the only
game that is running pretty damn
smoothly at at least medium settings or
high settings as it were and I think if
we brought it down even more for certain
things you know if you tweak it and as
you should be tweaking the settings for
this thing for different games you be
have you have a SW experience with
anything that you're playing so I think
with that you can get to our conclusion
the Lenova Legion go is a worthy
contender in the ring of handheld PCS
but of course like the rest of them on
the market you need to take note that in
the interest of battery usage and not
melting your console you're going to be
running most recent AAA titles at the
lowest settings however that's usually
not what Gamers who own these devices
are gunning for older games and some AAA
titles indie games and emulators are the
focal points of handheld PC gaming and
in that with the few games we play it
succeeds in bringing a comfortable
enough experience on a really pretty
screen with a great touchpad I have to
say again with heptic feedback and
reliable controls with the need to
slightly tweak performance settings on
the legion go in game and the controls
to fit your needs the real question is
will you get one let me know in the
comments below and if you have any
questions let us know there as well and
we'll do our best to get to them make
sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button it goes a long way in
helping out the channel in any case this
is Zin have a great week and I'll catch
youall
soon
[Music]
I